- When are we gonna get there? - Yeah, when?
- Water's gone. - And there's nothing left to eat.
- We're gonna die of thirst, aren't we? - We've about had it.
- We're finished, all right. Dead. - Stop this pathetic whining.
- But we can't live like this. - We are bacteria.
- And we need something to infect, but we can't find anything.
- So what's the plan? - Now look here, can you tell me what kind of bacteria you are?
- Oh, that's easy, boss. We're nasty, horrible, revolting bacteria.
Don't show off your ignorance, you hulking great imbecile, you Nicolai's bacilli, that's us, the tetanus microbe.
Well, I never just fancy that I'm Nicolai.
Oh, no, you're not.
Hey, if anybody is going to be called Nicolai, see to you, yeah?
Oh, they have your punch on me, booms. I'm the only one with that name.
You can all shut up and pay some attention to me before you do kill yourselves.
I know how to save our lives.
We bury ourselves. First, we find a hole.
I don't want to be buried.
Don't you interrupt me when I'm telling you something that's beyond your pea brain.
We'll become spores.
How can I become a spore when I don't know what it is?
We wrap ourselves up in a protective covering.
As spores, we can survive for months, even years, until the time is ripe.
Ripe for what?
To set up an infection.
As spores, we have a brilliant future ahead of us.
Now follow me and we'll look for a suitable resting place.
This will do nicely. We're safe. Now we can turn into spores.
Okay, but hell.
It's easy.
Now we look just like harmless little spores.
Nobody will suspect that we're actually dangerous tetanus germs.
And time is on our side, all the time in the world.
Those bushes come on beautifully, absolutely gorgeous, but it looks a little cramped to me.
I think I ought to transplant it.
Peter, run along now, you'll be late for school.
See you later, Mummy.
We're going to be late.
Sorry, Peter.
Jambo won't be coming to school with you today.
He's got a nasty cold, and his mum decided to keep him at home.
Will you let him know about any homework, eh?
Hello. Do you think he'll be better tomorrow?
Dear me, yes. I should think so, Peter.
Hurry up now. You don't want to be late for school, do you?
Okay, bye.
Bye.
Children, before I forget, class will finish a little early today
because you all have to go for your vaccinations.
Sir, do we have to be vaccinated? Doesn't it hurt?
What's the jab for, sir?
No, it's not sore, Mary.
It's to prevent you getting tetanus, which is a very serious illness indeed.
Sir, can tetanus kill?
No doubt about it. Tetanus can be fatal.
And with the vaccine?
No, no, no, then you're quite safe, as long as you don't forget your boosters.
That's not so bad.
You guys, it didn't hurt one tiny little bit.
It's nothing to worry about, I tell you.
Alistair, it's your turn now.
Wow, roses are beautiful.
Rambo, have you finished yet?
Yes, this exercise wasn't easy, you know.
So what should we play it now, Peter?
Come with me, I want to show you something super.
What do you think of this rose bush?
I've never seen so many flowers.
I know.
It would look even better if the roots had more room to grow.
It needs to be transplanted.
Do you reckon we could manage the job?
Yes, I've done it before.
You have to dig a fairly deep hole so that you don't break any roots.
Then you spread compost and water it well.
Come on while I fetch a couple of spades.
Heart digging over there, Jumbo.
Fine, Jumbo. This is the compost we'll need.
Oh, it tricked me.
Me too.
Thorns are a nuisance, aren't they?
Now, lift!
Come gently.
Macrophages, calling all macrophages.
Report to Zone 8 immediately.
Come along now, macrophages.
I'm dragging your feet muscles, that oxygen must be delivered today!
Aye, uh, boss?
Inside the body of a human being, just as I planned.
He invited us in by digging in the garden with an open scratch on his skin.
Ha ha, poor fool, now we take over his whole body!
Stylemen, our first priority is to fill our empty belly.
It'll be ready in a minute.
How about adding a pinch of salt?
Good idea, it'll improve the taste.
poison left behind when we finished eating tetanus toxins that attack the nervous system
just you wait and see the trouble they're going to cause once they get stuck into the nervous
system that's when the fun really starts here are our friends hello what oh i don't believe it
are you playing a practical joke on me lieutenant yes she is younger what can we do for you i would
like to identify some suspicious characters who are trying to cause trouble down in my blood vessel
I repeat, I would like to identify-
Okay, Lieutenant, we're on our way.
Dangerous poisons? I think it's tetanus.
Tetanus, you say?
Well, that's certainly no great problem for us, because we've been vaccinated.
Our antibodies can deal with these toxins in a matter of minutes.
You'll see.
Vaccinated?
Exactly. Our antibodies know precisely what to expect from those toxins.
So shall we release them, Captain?
Releasing antibody battalions now!
Tetanus toxins, of all things.
This is going to be an unexpected pleasure, my friends.
It's tetanus, brothers. Up on Atom and take no prisoners!
Come, sir, the world will be a prettier place without you.
Don't give me that, you fart, now, smarty.
If we do better than that, shall we carry on with the lesson?
For one and one for two!
How considerate of you, sir, to make this contest less boring for me!
Sir Toxum, since you seem so bent on self-destruction,
I shall make your own quietus for you with a bare budkin.
Say your prayers, Blue Bottle.
Dead for a ducat, dead.
Not a single toxin left.
Well, Lieutenant, it was to be expected.
After all, any vaccinated organism is full of trained antibodies
who quickly put pay to invaders.
We have just seen what happened inside Peter's body
when the tetanus germs failed to gain a foothold.
What about Jumbo?
He was absent from school on the day he should have been vaccinated.
What will happen to him now?
Poor Jumbo.
That's what's left over when we've finished eating.
So long as there are no antibodies to stop them, they can paralyze the body.
Hello? Get me the flying squad quickly, please. This is Lieutenant Jumbo speaking.
We'll see if we can identify those flying objects for you, Jumbo. Hang on.
How about you, Lieutenant?
Obviously, we haven't been vaccinated. I'm afraid we may be running into danger.
Down there, that antibody doesn't recognize them either.
What are your orders, Captain? Should I signal headquarters?
Before we do that, we'd better find out what they're up to.
Alert the airborne units at the next junction.
I'm going to follow this one.
Guess where we home in on a nerve.
This is where our training pays off.
Excellent, we're on target.
Captain Peter calling headquarters.
I've followed a group of intruders as far as a nerve ending.
They're still in there, Colonel.
Inside a nerve, eh?
I don't like it, Captain.
This could be extremely dangerous.
Oh, Jumbo.
Remember the other day when we got our anti-tetanus jabs at school and we...
Anti-what jabs?
Tetanus.
What's tetanus?
I've never had an injection for tetanus.
Meanwhile, in the nerve cell nearest to the branch where the toxins are hiding,
it's business as usual in the nuclear control room.
Washing his hands now. Everything's going according to plan.
We might as well put our feet up, huh?
Too predictable. Digital pronator muscles are now contracting,
the wrist muscles are relaxing, and the abductor muscle of the thumb is relaxed.
No problems.
Me, they should be put away for life!
You know, this is the northbound lane, isn't it?
It is. Nerves are one way.
one way? I think I've lost my message. You can always help me deliver mine if you like. All the
signals are different. If one goes missing, the muscles won't work together properly. That's right.
You'll have to stay behind and look for your message while I carry on alone. No, wait. If you
arrive before I do, the muscles still won't work together properly. Oh. No, it isn't. Matter, Jumbo?
I don't know. It's funny, Peter. My hand's not working properly. Far from normal. Look how the
muscle seems to be trembling. Is it a cramp, do you think? Goodness, something is definitely wrong
here. Let me have a look at the screen over here. Oh, dear me. Some of the signals are
not getting through. This is serious. I'll have to tell the chief. Maestro, maestro,
maestro, there's a slight problem, sir. What's that, eh? What's that noise? What's this
all about? Good heavens, toxins. There's absolutely no time to waste. This is a major emergency.
We must mobilize our defenses. Jump to it, men. Time is of the essence. General alert.
Our transmissions are about to be cut off by an invasion of toxins affecting the nerves.
S.O.S. We are in extreme danger. Please come to our aid.
Danger, I repeat, danger, danger.
The nerve has gone dead. I can't transmit.
Will somebody please tell me what's going on here?
Does it hurt?
Not really. My jaw's a bit stiff.
How long has it been like that?
Since yesterday. That's when I first noticed that I was clenching my teeth.
Tell me, have you had any cuts or grazes recently?
Uh, no, I don't think so.
You're dead certain?
Yes.
Hey, Jumbo, you're forgetting the rose bush.
So I am.
We were transplanting a rose bush,
and I got a tiny scratch in my hand from a thorn that pricked me.
And you too?
Yes, Doctor.
I got a little scratch too, but it's all healed up now.
I take it you boys had your anti-tet jabs at school?
I don't know, I can't remember.
Peter says we had them, but I can't remember.
But it wasn't very long ago, Jumbo.
The injection didn't hurt at all.
You must remember it.
Of course! You were sick that day. You're not vaccinated.
And so it seems that this unfortunate young man missed his anti-tetanus injection.
Tetanus is a serious complaint caused by microbes found in the soil or in dirt.
Now, these microbes produce a toxin, a poison that acts on the nervous system.
That's why we have to act very, very quickly.
So what's the next step, Doc?
I'm admitting him to hospital.
It'll be easier to keep a close eye on him there.
Bumblebee's doing the my quest!
Yeah, put him down. They're not movies. They're toxins.
That's poison very cleverly produced by ourselves.
So where are they flying off to, boss?
Oh, they'll wander through the bloodstream and mess up a few nerves here and there
until they're ready for the final objective.
Great danger here is that the brain stem and the spinal cord could be affected.
We must prevent that at all costs.
Sweeties! Who'll buy my delicious Sweetie Pies?
Very cheap today! Sweeties! Sweeties!
Now, what's that buzzing?
Proceed no further!
Produce your papers at once!
I've got no papers to produce, fat boy,
'cause I'm a nasty, horrible toxin,
and I'm not afraid of the likes of you, so then...
We'll see.
Ehhh!
Okay, your careers are over!
Grrrr!
Stop us now, so come on!
Antibodies!
These don't recognize the toxins.
None of our fighters have had the special training they need
to wipe out these toxins.
Spreading like wildfire!
Come in headquarters, we're in trouble!
Purified anti-tetanus serum.
This is our best chance to save the boy.
This ought to do the trick, nurse.
Antibiotics.
I can't take much more of this.
Eyes off.
So, hapless denizens of this human body,
be you platelets or capustles,
we have come to rid you of the plague.
These loathsome toxin flies who rule the roost,
or so they think,
will get a rude awakening from us chevaliers.
Have at them a very palpable hit.
Dead.
For a ducat, I say.
They've come just in time.
The toxins have got the upper hand.
We may have missed out on vaccination, but now, fortunately, we've got the next best thing.
Anti-Tetanus Serum.
Our doctor friend outside the body has very powerful weapons.
Look, Lieutenant, now the battle's really going to begin in earnest.
Men!
Those antibodies have really got it in for us, I'm telling you.
Get angry with them, lads.
Smash their faces in and do the worst you can.
That's the only way we'll win, okay, okay?
You mustn't fight, men!
That's all we can do for him at present.
We'll just have to wait for the serum to take effect.
It shouldn't be very long.
It'll kill the toxins while the antibiotic wipes out the germs.
When we get to the skin, that's where we're delivering our oxygen.
Look at this.
It's like antibiotic to me.
We must be close to them now.
Antibodies. There must be microbes about with all this military traffic.
Going to be a war?
Oh yes, I should think so, child.
Those are the antibodies of an antibiotic, a medicine made to fight microbes.
The war will go on until all the microbes are dead.
We're almost on them.
The idea is to take them by surprise before they've had time to multiply.
Follow me, antibodies!
These two mosquitoes can't hurt a germ like me.
You can't bash me.
Miss me. Try again.
Whoopsie.
You have to do better than that.
Over here. This way, you great ox.
Okay, chaps.
Punch her the spin bag. He's full of hot air.
Lieutenant Claire of the Lymphocyte Patrol calling.
Please send in the macrophages to mop up.
The tetanus infection has been completely eliminated.
Over and out.
Swords, my gallant band of antibodies.
Tis time they should be blooded.
The choice awaits us.
Death or glory.
Charge!
You fellows, give them everything you've got.
Use your boots and teeth if you have to.
Charge!
Porter, given or asked.
Have at you.
A hit.
A very palpable hit.
Ha ha.
Next, please.
Oh, we'll wipe each other out this.
Stupid.
I'm going to puddle off.
Look behind you, Metro.
One of them's trying to get away.
We don't want him to become a new source of infection.
Grab this and hold on tight.
To be...
B is the question.
Well, my young friend, you've had a narrow escape, no mistake about it.
Tetanus can kill you, no, but we were lucky to catch you at an early stage.
Everyone should be vaccinated.
Doctor, vaccines for other diseases?
Good heavens, yes, there are dozens of them.